¿Sabíais que hay un país en Sudamérica
donde la mayor parte de la población es de
origen indio y el inglés es el idioma oficial?
Si no sabes a que país me estoy refiriendo,
no te preocupes, porque este es uno de los
países más desconocidos de toda la región
y, la verdad, para ser justos, no es habitual
que los medios de comunicación se refieran
siquiera a él.
País pequeño, poco conocido, los medios
no hablan de él..
¡Exacto, los ingredientes perfectos para
un vídeo de VisualPolitik!
Hablamos de Guyana, una antigua colonia británica
que no obtuvo su independencia hasta 1966.
Por cierto: En ese momento tanto el gobierno
como el estado de ánimo general apostaban
por convertir el país en un estado socialista,
y precisamente de ese deseo proviene su curioso
nombre oficial: la República COOPERATIVA
de Guyana.
Pero…
No nos desviemos.
Guyana es uno de los países más pobres y
con mayores tasas de criminalidad y violencia
de toda Sudamérica, y, claro, dadas las circunstancias
eso es mucho decir.
De hecho, amigos, la situación es tan desalentadora
que, si este país es conocido por algo, es
por ser una referencia en la distribución
internacional de cocaína y por tener, cuidado,
la mayor tasa de suicidios del mundo.
Con estos datos, no parece que podamos ser
muy optimistas con el futuro de este país.
¿Verdad?
Sin embargo, su suerte está a punto de cambiar.
UNA NUEVA POTENCIA PETROLIFERA
Todo apunta a que Guyana está a punto de
ingresar en el club de las potencias petroleras.
De momento, esta pequeña república de poco
más de 750.000 habitantes ya ha conseguido
captar la atención y sobre todo los dólares
de multinacionales tan importantes como Exxon
Mobil o Hess Corporation.
De hecho, tras varios años de exploraciones
en la zona, el pasado 13 de enero de 2017,
estos dos titanes de la industria del petróleo
anunciaron el descubrimiento del que creen
puede ser uno de los mayores yacimientos de
petróleo y gas descubierto en décadas.
Los pozos se han encontrado en aguas profundas,
en el manto marino bajo las aguas costeras
de Guyana, y las primeras estimaciones, ojo,
barajan que la cantidad de petróleo que se
puede explotar en este país no es inferior
a los 4.000 millones de barriles de petróleo,
y no son pocos los expertos que afirman que
la cantidad puede ser muy superior.
Es decir, todo apunta a que, en el peor de
los casos, este pequeño país, alberga una
inmensa fortuna, pero...
¿Cuánto supone realmente todo esto?
Teniendo en cuenta el precio actual del petróleo
hablamos de más de 200.000 millones de dólares.
Es decir, dejando a un lado el gas natural
y otros muchos recursos naturales, solo el
petróleo le reportaría a Guyana una riqueza
equivalente a un cuarto de millón de dólares
por habitante.
E, insisto, las reservas de petróleo podrían
ser, incluso, mucho mayores.
Es verdad, explotar petróleo no es gratis,
y desde luego se requieren inversiones enormes,
pero precisamente estas podrían suponer el
primer paso de una nueva época de enorme
prosperidad para Guyana.
Tan solo las dos compañías de petróleo
que he mencionado, Exxon Mobil y Hess se han
comprometido a invertir en Guyana 900 millones
de dólares anuales durante los próximos
años.
Y el gobierno quiere hacer lo propio.
La idea es poder empezar a exportar petróleo
en 2020.
Es decir, Guyana podría estar a las puertas
del mayor proceso de crecimiento de desarrollo
y crecimiento de toda la historia de Sudamérica.
Sí, Guyana se podría llegar a convertir
en ese país en el que piensas cuando no tienes
trabajo y te dices a ti mismo:
Quiero cambiar de vida, quiero tener una oportunidad.
Guyana podría convertirse en la gran esperanza
para muchas personas de Latinoamérica.
Ahora bien, antes de que empecéis a hacer
las maletas, tenemos que decir que no va a
ser tan fácil, el camino está plagado de
dificultades.
CONFLICTO CON VENEZUELA
Muchos de las exploraciones se están realizando
en aguas que son reclamadas como propias por
Venezuela.
Bueno, de hecho, no se puede decir que la
parte reclamada por Venezuela sea precisamente
pequeña.
El país de Nicolás Maduro considera como
propia la región conocida como Guyana Esequiba
que representa más del 70% de la superficie
total de Guyana!
¡Vamos que Venezuela reclama casi todo el
país!
Por si esto no fuese suficiente, otro 7% del
territorio del país es reclamado por su vecino
Surinam.
Es decir, que si fuese por sus vecinos a Guyana
le quitaban hasta la letras del nombre.
El caso es que durante años el conflicto
estuvo congelado, probablemente gracias a
las buenas relaciones que el gobierno tenía
con Cuba, y ya sabéis lo influyente que es
la Habana en esta zona del mundo,
y también debido a que durante años Venezuela
quiso ganarse el apoyo de organizaciones como
el CARICOM, la Comunidad del Caribe, a al
cual pertenece la Guyana.
Sí, amigos, la Guyana es geográficamente
un país sudamericano, pero política, social
y culturalmente es sobre todo un país caribeño.
De hecho, Guayan era una de los países beneficiarios
del programa PetroCaribe, una iniciativa de
Hugo Chávez que consistía en proveer de
petróleo barato y en condiciones inmejorables
a países “amigos”.
Pero esta situación cambio el 11 de mayo
de 2015, cuando el gobierno de izquierdas
del Partido Progresista del Pueblo, perdió
las elecciones contra una coalición encabezada
por el nuevo Presidente David Granger, un
hombre mucho más cercano a Washington y decidido
a terminar de una vez con las reivindicaciones
de Caracas.
En ese momento, el conflicto se descongeló
y las declaraciones subieron mucho de tono.
“Venezuela impone sanciones a Guyana”.
Hoy el conflicto está en manos de la ONU,
pero está claro que con independencia de
cómo se resuelva, si es que lo hace, esta
es una importante amenaza para ese futuro
de grandes alegrías que puede lograr Guyana.
CONFLICTO RACIAL
Otro importante foco de riesgo se encuentra
en un conflicto racial que recurrentemente
salta a la primera plana de la actualidad
de la Guyana.
Este país tiene una composición demográfica
relativamente compleja: alrededor del 50%
de la población es de origen india, mientras
que aproximadamente un 40% es de origen africano.
Es decir, hay dos grandes grupos demográficos,
que no son precisamente amigos entre sí.
De hecho, la minoría negra denuncia que durante
años la mayoría india ha hecho y deshecho
a su antojo, obteniendo privilegios del gobierno.
Eso ha desencadenado durante años recurrentes
olas de violencia.
Por fortuna, la situación parece haber mejorado.
De hecho, la coalición que ganó las últimas
elecciones, tenía un marcado carácter multirracial.
Sin embargo, el riesgo continua sobre la mesa.
En cualquier caso, ese nuevo gobierno no solo
supone una gran oportunidad para superar estos
enfrentamientos de una vez por todas, sino
que fue elegido para luchar contra la corrupción
– Guyana, ojo, es uno de los países más
corruptos del mundo, según Tranpsarencia
internacional – y la violencia.
Sí, podemos decir que, aparentemente, la
explotación del petróleo, la lucha contra
la corrupción y la lucha contra la delincuencia
son los tres pilares del nuevo gobierno.
El caso es que, si lo consigue, Guyana dará
mucho de qué hablar, y tal vez pueda aspirar
a convertirse, si hacen un uso inteligente
de los recursos, en el nuevo Dubái latinoamericano
¿lo veremos?
Esa es la pregunta.
En fin, ¿qué pensáis vosotros?
¿Será capaz Guyana de extraer todo el beneficio
potencial que tiene el petróleo descubierto?
¿Qué posición debe adoptar Venezuela?
Bueno, como siempre, espero que este vídeo
os haya resultado interesante.
Sí ha sido así, dadle al botón de like
y suscribiros al canal.
Por cierto, si queréis saber por qué India
puede convertirse en una nueva super potencia,
haced click aquí.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!